[Music]
here's a quick tip from someone we love
hi i'm courtney mack williams i'm the
founder of marymax doggie retreat in new
orleans louisiana and this is gabana i'm
a social worker and i specialize in
overly anxious dogs many facilities
where they're going to abort your dog
offer daycare so have their daycare at
least
two weeks prior to you leaving and
boarding your dog
at least two to three times
that way they're comfortable they know
the staff
it's not a stressful environment for
them that's one of my tips when you're
introducing your pet to a new
environment i would say take them out of
the home starting 10 minutes at a time
to different environments to see how
they would respond what will be good and
comforting for them is
anything that reminds them of home like
their favorite blanket
toy
or
bed even their crate um because
sometimes the crates are their safe spot
that'll help reduce some anxiety if a
thunderstorm is coming and you want to
calm your dog you can use a thunder
jacket but if you don't have a thunder
jacket you can use an old pair of tights
and use their high to their trigger
points right
the nip of the neck
the chest
chest right here
and the back the lower back
you want to swaddle them like a baby
when you tie the tights but you want to
leave the paws
free and the tail free cuddling with
your dog and reading a good book not
only helps to reduce the anxiety of the
dog but as well as the owner
i love animals i'm dr drew little
[Music]